kick me in the ass but I'm telling the
truth kids today wouldn't know what that
is you were looking at the mob guys as
your friends it's Catania you want to
get a slice if I come from a boxing
background you're not going to screw
around with Rich Mancuso
my doctor don't want to see that right
we came here we struggling that's what's
missing you didn't get home at 5 30 you
didn't eat a Brazilian Calabria and
Naples same with me crazy seriously
Antonio has not changed a thing since
the 50s huh that's why it got so huge
eating this stuff all my life if you set
up a novela that's a curse
you better run go back to Florida we
don't give up we fight for our values we
believe in our culture
[Music]
good afternoon guys the best stories are
usually told through locals that have
history and experience So today we're
going to meet up with an old school
Italian-American Rich Mancuso who's
going to bring us into his nostalgic
lens of New York City we're going to go
through his history here what he's seen
but also get his take on what things are
currently like here in 2021.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh man the best you know I mean really
good Italian regular Italian food but
like the bread bakeries yeah you can't
find better bread anywhere all right so
have fun thank you Rich how you doing
we shaking we doing this what do you
want I don't know I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore let me show you this first come
here
all right we're in Rich say hi take this
mask off first yeah okay you don't have
to wear it outside it was up to where
when we go somewhere indoors yeah so
this was all Italian back in the day
yeah basically in fact I'm going to show
you now the Bronx Tale okay everyone
knows the movie here's the mural
what's the movie The Bronx Tale God I
haven't seen it oh wow do I need to go
home now you can watch it come back you
need to see it because everyone has seen
it she's based on this day but we're
back in the 60s women it was the racial
the division okay he didn't want any
blacks or Latinos in the neighborhood
and in the Bronx Tales based on that a
lot and about the mob guys that try to
keep the neighborhood safe here's a
mural of it right here all right
you might want to see that
you know when you think of Italians in
New York you think of I mean the
tourists think of Little Italy but this
was it right this was known as a Little
Italy it still is
Little Italy the Bronx we're very far
from Manhattan yeah Mulberry streets
Little Italy of New York but this is
literally the Bronx at one time this
community was was designated by the FBI
is the safest neighborhood in New York
City how's it now now
okay unfortunate and and I'm not
I'm not going to fault anyone yeah but
to tell you that when I grew up here
on these streets here and what we're
gonna see right
the mob influence the mob guy really
kept it safe it was the mob keeping it
safe not the cops yeah because right the
cops were you know the part of it
they worked with them they worked with
the community We Had A Beat cop
ah you don't have that no more we had
one cop or two they knew the whole
neighborhood walked around with the
billy club
and when you saw that cop you ran away
because you didn't know let's just say
you have a business every one of these
shops was Panda the Italian mob
no okay and then worked that way how'd
it work see that's a misconception they
did not control businesses and
very kind-hearted people that helped the
community
not like what you saw in The Sopranos
with Tony Soprano and them making sure
that they controlled the businesses took
the rent or whatever no that's not what
it was like here that's a misconception
what what they did was
protect the community
they helped people
they made sure these streets were safe
and as a result when they were put away
and the cops couldn't control and then
the landlords took over these buildings
when Section 8 in this neighborhood
changed
so how are they making their money then
they did things that were illegal we
know that okay so were they selling
drugs or nothing when I was around them
not me I didn't see that okay
all of that might be going on I never
saw it
okay it was the illegal racket game of
numbers okay gambling which now is not
an issue at all because it's all legal
now right this is the main street 187th
okay and you'll still see the Italian
presence with the pastry shops oh yeah
that old school pictures are places that
weren't here when I grew up uh there's a
little over there are two sold which was
the most popular one down the clock and
we'll go see Jerome if he's in Geno's
pastry we'll take a walk there okay
we're gonna go to a pastry shop yeah
we're gonna get some Italian food is
that a possibility I was gonna do that
at cutaneous I want to okay
Sicilian huh Sicilian and a mini calzone
okay guys the sponsor of today's video
is Cuts clothing I like making videos
but I hate shopping luckily I found the
best T-shirt of my life that works for
everything from walking the streets in
the Bronx with Rich Mancuso to
sweltering Heat at the Texas border to
going out with my wife for dinner this
shirt does it all the older I get the
more I realize that quality is important
Cuts makes products that last no
stretching worn out collar ironing or
pilling I've used and abused these
shirts and they are indestructible and
fantastic for traveling yes they cost
more than your average t-shirt but you
get what you pay for with cuts they also
have stylish hoodies and long sleeve
shirts if you want one of the most
durable slash stylish t-shirts I've come
across after years of searching here's
the best one I found at a discount to
receive 15 off your order click on the
cuts link below in the description or
use the promo code Peter at checkout
again that's Peter at checkout I
wouldn't recommend something to you that
I didn't fully believe in or use myself
if you want the best T-shirt of your
life give cuts a try people come from
all over the country all over the world
to eat here down here that's some of the
popular eateries here restaurants and
even Beyond on another blog all right
we're gonna go down there too I'm going
to show you where my old social club was
sometimes people don't like the way I
talk about it and I say that I'm
anti-iness no it's not that I'm telling
the truth right I am I didn't grow up my
mother father taught me and my two
brothers never ever to be Prejudiced and
to hate okay to get along with everyone
and that's what I've done all my life I
still do I grow I grew up with Latinos
and blacks all my life it's because I'm
involved with sports all my life but
never had any hate or never biased or
some group over another yes I'm an
Italian and I'm very very proud of my
Heritage yeah as an Italian-American and
I always will be yeah and I also feel
coming out of this neighborhood that
Italians don't get the credit they
rightfully deserve
contributing so much to society every
walk on passion of Life yeah from the
Arts to the culture to to the food to
inventions I mean Enrico Fermi this one
that one even Christopher Columbus yeah
and then we got Christopher Columbus
that's under attack this is what I love
about your generation that we're
starting to lose a bit yeah I'm not
young either but the South authenticity
you know there's this love for craft and
like Mom and Pop type shop going away
young people going away to young people
today
in the Bronx in the city and it's
everywhere but here
if they would not know what we did and
what we went through times weren't easy
what do you mean by that well you're
saying it's not as good now right you're
saying like it's going it wasn't great
back then either okay but the one thing
that was great is we had a stable
household a mother a father
today that don't exist
I mean I've worked well it does for half
the people right I've worked with kids
all my life and I see more and more a
lot of young people don't know who their
mom real mom is or Malone more so who
their real dad yeah we always had that
structure my house and most in this
community knew who the mom and dad was
who the brother and sister was and and
that that contributed a lot to making
this neighborhood strong
because there was a problem
if a merchant knew you did something
wrong they knew your mom or dad okay if
a cop didn't beat cop music something
wrong they knew your mom or dad and that
wasn't fun to deal with Mom and Dad no
it wasn't right not at my house I have
an Italian-American father
yeah and it was he was he was hard
that you did wrong
let him rest in peace dad died too young
okay you got the strap yeah
okay oh yeah and if you saw that belt
come out you ran for cover if you look
above that blue yawning uh-huh well
that's what a restaurant was and that
apartment Window right there with the
air conditioner is where job as she
lived
before he was famous yeah
so a lot of our big uh Italian-American
Stars grew out of this neighborhood yes
some of them are transformative Joe
Pesci sent the Great Club of his youth
here Sicilian Calabria and Naples same
with me
seriously it's a crazy thing seriously
seriously yeah so that's classified
Italian American yeah yeah you don't
call yourself Italian though you are but
you're an American you're born here an
Italian American how many generations
are you think I can go back
because I'm Tech you know my DNA comes
from that part of the world
um but I you know I can't claim I'm
Italian but I do I tell you Italian food
does bring about warmth we always had
pastas every Sunday like made in my
grandmother's pot you know Sunday dinner
just like they did in Italy three
o'clock
it was on the table it was a festival of
Miami it was big did yours always end an
argument in college okay
too it wasn't just Sundays it was
holidays right that's just a part of how
we are what is that highly emotional
right there's an expression coming out
of Naples in a tank or you can go half
an hour if you said Alpha nabla that's a
curse
and you better run but here's author
Revenue okay which hasn't changed
except for a few
okay yes a few stores stickball sponge
ball kickball
uh Johnny on a pony yeah
we we managed uh ping pong against the
wall with a sponge with a with a
spalding ball stage they called it yeah
a Scully in the street with the Caps we
used to take I know what that is well
what we did is we used to go to the cars
and we used to we used to steal and take
their Tire caps and put that on a bottle
cam opener
and put that data give it friction in
the street and you had to just use your
finger to go like that
and try and get it into a hole like
Circle okay and we all did it that was
our fun how's the kids today wouldn't
know what that is
how'd that go over though with people
did you get the beat down if you're a
cot no they helped they played with us
all right
so you were looking at the mob guys as
as uh your friends they made me
look at things that others wouldn't seem
you know well life
okay
[Music]
they would she wouldn't have that you
hear that we know that what Mexican
music all of that loud music whatever it
is you didn't have Italian music no not
like that not like that well this is the
car systems weren't that good back then
well we did still we wouldn't do it it's
called respect
uh you're looking that as disrespectful
very why because it's because it's it
because it's it it's it's noisy
and people don't want to be around that
you know why must you drive around in a
car make all that noise when there's
other people around that don't it's
totally unnecessary what are they trying
to prove by doing that kick me in the
ass but I'm telling the truth
I'm trying to stay straight all right I
don't have the ring on my finger you
punched them oh yeah I knocked them out
I come from a boxing background so
you're not going to screw around with
Rich Mancuso but I stay away from it but
if you're gonna attack me I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna make my point you're gonna
stay on your ground sure all right don't
mess with Rich wow I'm getting older so
I
like
my mom and dad love that place they
would yeah no no it's owned by a Jewish
guy okay an Italian figure that out hey
I got a joke for you if uh a Jew and an
Italian go to go into business who loses
money
Italian always wins I think this is a
Jew and Italian go to business together
who loses money who loses money and the
Italian doesn't lose the money the
government oh all right go back to
Florida will you look
okay
that then became a Umberto's Clam House
the one that happened with Lydia
Mulberry Street yeah and they since it's
not no more this used to be the movie
theater in the neighborhood known as
ginelli's which was ever known as the
dumps
we come here on Saturday so the matinee
to Kitty matinee watch a cartoon in a
movie right here but it was called the
dumps because it was filthy
okay I mean you know I got the names of
the Thomas because he would see a rat
once in a while underneath the seats
scared the hell out of everyone in the
theater should be movie theater
janelli's and there was one maitre d who
would be the babysitter for all of us on
a Saturday she she dreaded that job but
she did it became the mother hen to all
of us though okay so all the mom used to
throw a quarter from the window
and that was your afternoon in here
it was like a babysitter yeah she'd send
all the kids are coming from the window
she'd throw it down and took a as part
of your allowance that you got on a
Saturday okay tell the kid today what an
allowances they wouldn't know that
25 cents 50 cents would get you a whole
day in here your movies your soda your
popcorn your hot dog whatever you needed
let's go around I know it's a beautiful
Library broadcasters writers
Antonio's
yeah
Antonio has not changed the thing since
the 50s huh look he's he's hiring I
wanted the cows you want this bread yeah
let's let's try some they were open I
think like that wall is not changed
the secondary store which is just you
know get the same thing
an old ceiling yeah
[Music]
good and now I grew up with them
freshly made every day fine still not
that's why I got so huge eating this
stuff all my life
he's back in a moment
bye-bye the market
so you can't beat oh wow fantastic
[Music]
this was here when you were growing up
rich yeah probably Jim
oh fresh how you guys doing it's okay if
I video this all right
no charge all right you got all the
sausages here on the get the fresh how
you doing
nine types of sauce I've known him since
he was a kid you're right I mean he's
almost 13. wow what do you mean 52 years
man what have you seen in the
neighborhood I'm sure you could talk for
hours on that but what are the big
things changes you've seen wow a lot of
different people different ethnic groups
or it used to be you know strictly
mainly old Italian you know descending
immigrants you know now we got a lot of
uh big influx of Mexicans and albanians
good workers good people yeah still the
Italians they used to come here you know
years ago with you know with their
mothers right you know now they're
coming back to basics first you know
outside this neighborhood everything is
like supermarkets that's it you're not
going to find nothing like this anywhere
else in the world I live up in Rockland
all you see is Costco's and BJ's this is
like an endangered species oh it is it
is I mean there's not that many left of
us left you know Arena to you know to
find a butcher so why are the Italians
having the Italian Americans having kids
what's going on why they're they're
having kids why they're not having kids
wow it's too expensive to have kids
that's what it is
[Music]
you know they don't want to get their
hands dirty work at 12 14 hours a day
it's impossible if you find somebody
that wants to work if you don't have a
hair you can't work it you can't hire me
yeah I was born there so I came in when
I was 13. yes where yeah oh yeah the
Adriatic side yeah yeah the heel of
Italy yeah you ever go back to 13 oh
yeah I've been back about five times
yeah what do you think when you go back
to Italy and you come back to the States
what do you think you know I would love
to you know I love I love Italy I press
your body I love the lifestyle or once
you're used to this after 50 years you
know I mean it's very it's very hard to
look back but I've never lifestyle I
mean it's so much calmer you know they
really
they enjoy life let's put it this way
but you know I don't want to say they
have no goals in life we came here we
struggled we struggled we always wanted
always on the rush you know you want a
bigger house you want a cars you want to
give us education to your kids it's more
summer more like calm well there's no
pulse exactly no pulse you know that's
what I call my wife yeah it's nice to
visit in a month to weeks two weeks but
to live there after you lose to 50 years
here you can do it yeah you gotta come
back yeah so so you're saying down the
road when your generation yeah not for a
long time but I'm just saying you know
there's no one coming in to fill the
place no no it's it's all going to be
pre-packaged stuff you know I mean just
give me on YouTube
television
you come here a lot yeah
I'm not alive
this is the place huh yeah thank you
we're talking to you buddy I appreciate
it
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think of the music rich
[Music]
and they play it at Citi Field where I
where I am a lot with the Mets covering
the Mets that's on no Lazy Mary
you can't stand it I can't stand it
because it's an insult to Italians this
is Mario's original restaurant why
because it says Lazy Lazy Mary it
insults Italians the Italian woman and
the female
[Music]
close it's a Monday to go
is Pasquale's Rigoletto
let's go uh let's go get a meal
yeah we'll stop in Catania after we look
at the Columbus bus
see the neighborhood completely downhill
when you go past here
what happens past here oh you've got the
activity that's
good
it's actually open today
this was a move this used to be by the
old Columbus Boys Club they moved it
here to this park and it's a subject of
controversy because Columbus dated it's
guarded because there have been all
types of threats that knock it down how
do you feel about that uh dead against
it what did this guy
Italian tradition leave it alone
leave it alone he's an Italian he's a
part about culture leave it alone so you
feel like your culture it's like
chipping away your culture okay you get
attacked too much and to go back to the
days when the mob guys were around if
they tried to do that
that would just be a threat and go fur
any further than a threat that would be
stopped yeah thank you so much
this is
that's culture
well built to leave it alone
any of those statues in the city
it annoys me Peter yeah
this is Preston Avenue this is another
straight
has some good restaurants on the corner
down further Antonio
at my old social club which is no more
was the middle left block right there
social club we had a club us young guys
24 7 that was our Hangout
there's a lot of beer drinking a lot of
parties a lot of fun grew up with all of
them a lot of them still are not around
no more
it was great growing up before the
internet huh we had the one oh yeah
guy named slim Willie Rodriguez Williams
[Music]
a merchant
people the old people he was such a
helpful caring young guy Willie died too
young Clinton we call them slim and he
ran that club and made sure the dudes
were paid he lived in there and he he
passed away in his sleep and I took that
bed because he was one of my one of my
best you know
is contagious you want to get a slice
yeah let's check this out it'd be
let me throw that away
[Music]
put that on camera because my doctor
don't want to see that oh the cigarette
what am I gonna do you were you were
smoking Richard well my doctor won't see
it yeah he won't see it
[ __ ]
what's going on here Katana with him and
his brothers how do you do
I didn't see you my feet my vision my
vision has gotten worse you got older
and I got older for you
oh yeah I'll do a slice of cheese pizza
I don't get over here as much as I'd
like you used to get here a lot more
often
how do you guys feel with Rich leaving
the neighborhood
[Music]
yes all right which has got a great
sense of humor he does yeah yeah I'm
like they don't make no more what about
you not me I ain't funny at all
[Music]
so guys tell me you're you're
Italian-American all right
yes
born in Italy where calabriel good pizza
straightforward New York New York Pizza
A little crisp at the bottom
good amount of cheese
very nice
this is the
mini calzone
that you could only get
a cutaneous when we've grown up you know
10 12 13 14 years old yeah after school
you dropped your folks home you did a
little homework that you got and you
went out and you played
5 5 30.
there was a bunch of whistles going off
and every kid knew which whistle was
this
that met dinner time every every parent
had a different whistle everything
from the window and five between five
and five thirty PM every kid was at the
dinner table Yeah Dinner seven nights
every night
Sundays it was like one o'clock three
o'clock one o'clock we ate at three
right so and that's what's missing
because if you didn't get home at 5 30
you didn't eat you didn't eat
you didn't eat you had to wait till
tomorrow you had a different menu
everything you had to wait till tomorrow
right and that was no more discipline at
home we got kicked in the ass plenty of
times yeah but
we stayed together
it's missing
as a word you think things are going
right now there's no discipline these
kids are doing whatever they want to do
oh yeah
to be feral older people always said
that though every every parent's always
said that right absolutely what do you
think this time's different you got in
trouble in the street growing up here
yeah
and somebody yelled at you or like
another parent
you did not go home and tell your
parents that you got yelled at by
another parent because if you did you
were wrong they yelled at you for a
reason they didn't yell at you for
nothing so so parents everyone's parents
were looking out for other guys too
absolutely that was called
um Community neighborhood but you don't
have anymore
there's no more communities there's no
more neighborhoods there's nothing
done that's depressing guys because now
they want uh I think the cops to be the
community back in the day it was
somebody else's parents that told you
hey what are you still doing here it's 5
30 don't you think you should be home
eating right if they were out or coming
home from work or whatever there was no
homeless there were no homes
we had the neighborhood bum you know
absolutely Miguel was still around but
he didn't sleep on the bench no and then
we had uh
Ozarks remember yeah
[Music]
my first time in this neighborhood it
looks pretty good
it's a lot better it was sort of so much
better if you think this is good there's
a lot of kids just kids running around
the streets and whatnot it was it was
leaks
in the in the neighborhood yeah like for
instance the softball league yeah it was
six 17s each kid each kid is from the
neighborhood
of kids always playing ball that's a lot
of kids basketball league remember the
best basketball league each block had
their own team everything
and that's the difference we don't give
up we fight for our values
we believe in our culture and we're
we're United people we all have money
but we have everything
you got great food you've heard you've
heard the expression about Italian De La
Familia this is
like these guys are not friends they've
been like family of the years I don't
see them every day sorry he said I
walked in here yeah I mean I wish I
could see him every day but that's part
of that growing up lovely yeah that's it
you deliver this yeah I'm gonna deliver
it right now where are you going I'm
going to Adam's Place you're just gonna
walk it there no ubereats
take care
[Music]
you're seeing it for the first time I'm
going back to the Pez
always been my favorite because my
mother used to make this homemade this
is where the mob hung up guys with you
if they needed a favor for me they got
it but I didn't want nothing back in
return from them except their love
he was in charge of the neighborhood
Frankie Frankie smog
back then he didn't settle things with
guns and knives those are the moves
those are the moves
cannoli will always be a cannoli now
it's um
I get emotional sneaking away from Mom
and Dad hey sweetheart yeah but they
used to watch from the window Here in My
Views to control this whole area who
controls the block now
oh
you cannot erase great memories